you ever been in this room before  no but you feel like you have  you feel out of place like your life  isn't your own  you don't know me this is all of the  evidence seized last Thursday night we  believe this is the man that murdered  coward Slade and Shane Fisher you knew  one of his victims if there's a link  we'll find it tell me what am I missing  there's no pattern it's just chaos you  can prove it to yourself Lucy think  Harold Slade I know that that name means  something to me remember  that was [ __ ] before why don't you start  at the beginning  you seem to have a distorted  relationship with time my perception of  time is better than anyone's  he's playing a game with us  Lucy this guy's the scenery I need this  to end  it's all connected to dreams your  memories everything that happens  everything that doesn't everything that  will  and in this delusion of yours are you a  time traveler or a fortune teller  neither  I'm a boss  [Music]